the mom accused of killing her
seven-year-old son and leaving his body
in a hiking
area near mountain springs admits to
killing him good afternoon i'm christian
costas
and i'm kirsten joyce 35 year old
samantha moreno rodriguez has made her
first appearance here in las vegas
she told police she choked her son
bianca holman reports from the newsroom
with what we learned today
in court samantha moreno rodriguez was
extradited here from denver earlier this
week
her court appearance today was a warrant
return hearing she faces one count of
murder in the death of her son
now according to liam houston's family
and police reports he was autistic
back in may moreno rodriguez left her
home in san jose california with liam
and they made a stop here in las vegas
in court the prosecution shared moreno
rodriguez became frustrated with liam
strangling him for about 15 minutes
she then took his clothes off and left
him in a hiking area near mountain
springs
after she drove to denver there police
tracked
her down the judge today did not grant
bail
the choking strangling the child
disposing of the body after
he was deceased and then going to
colorado
i do find that that burden was met now
if that we have a preliminary hearing
and there's an issue with that
confession this
will be readdressed okay i will always
leave that door open for you
but for right now the state did make its
burden i'm granting the state's request
she is remanded without bail when the
boy was found it took some time for him
to be identified a friend of the family
saw reports contacting san jose police
department
and liam's dead also during this
morning's court proceedings mourinho
rodriguez was assigned a public defender
she's expected to be back in court
august 3rd bianca holman
8 news now